so we've got this conflict going on in
the Middle East we haven't re you know
we haven't convened to even talk about
this since since it's happened um you
know we had people protesting on Capitol
Hill but they weren't called insurrectos
or anything like that they were I don't
know if they treated the same if they
were treated the same as what happened
when Donald Trump was President does
anybody have the details on that with
that in that not Insurrection but an
Insurrection yeah so a bunch of people
um I guess stormed the capital and were
protesting um similar to January 6 not
quite in but um according to the media
but um they were protesting saying free
Palestine and it's you know the thing is
is that it's not just that protest it's
pretty much everywhere um so as you
without giving up too much too many
details like so I live on a University
campus and um during the convocation
there were just half a dozen narcissists
that would just you know walked up when
they received the diplomas were saying
free Palestine all this you know and
it's just like it's this isn't this
isn't the place to to protest and to do
all this stuff though right and so it's
been happening all across the world
where people are holding protests for
this thing right you know and it's it's
um got a stand with the new thing right
exactly kind of like you know forgotten
about by now that's exactly well Ukraine
has been a year and a half though right
so and zalinski is still trying to
remain relevant by trying to visit
Israel you know as well yeah so and
that's kind of the thing and that it's
the new thing to protest like I I swear
like you know during the convocation
there were just easily um a dozen or
more people that were either either had
like the flag or they had like the scarf
that had the colors or they had like one
person actually like went up and
preached like gave a
sermon on the podium when they were
getting a degree just saying uh just
saying all this stuff though and it's
like this isn't the time or the place
though right you know yeah yeah I mean
whatever you know like I don't care you
know there's there's all this
that's going on around the world and
they're trying to get you to care about
and it's like you know the chapter in my
book about managing your FS is totally
relevant to what's going on when they're
trying to drag you in and stand with
whatever cause it's like let them like
whatever happened to let to just letting
them sus it out right why do we got to
get dragged in all this bull well
and and to be honest the thing is is
that like I'm not saying that you should
care but it is important in terms of
world geopolitics all right you know how
many you give is up to you but it
it's not like like you don't sit there
and and like you know and protest in
public though right on something that
has nothing to do with the actual event
though right do you know what I mean
yeah it I
mean it's just weird man you know it's
just weird
it's you know like you got the states
allied with Israel and then you've got
many citizens of the states allied with
Palestine um they didn't call the
protest and Insurrection I don't know if
they got treated the same or if they're
all to see a day in jail like some of
the guys during the January Insurrection
as they called it um it is what it is
dudes I mean uh it's just some
that's going on that they want to suck
you into to make you care about take a
side you know fight with something it's
just I just don't see the point and well
you know similar to to that is right now
they have the trial for the freedom
Convoy um protesters in Canada yeah
what's happening with that well so
they're looking at like jail time for
like Mischief they're looking at jail
time for parking their 18wheeler
trucks we don't want to be locked down
well but the thing is is that they're
not they're not actually Prosecuting
like the truckers they're Prosecuting
the people that organized the protest oh
the people that organized it that put it
together so they're they're charging
oh okay so it's okay when you get all
the weirdos with the purple hair and
they're 300 tons you know sitting on
Capitol Hills front step saying that you
know Transformer rights are everybody's
rights but when you know like other
people just don't want to get forced
vaccination or or get locked in their
house and that's then that's not cool
right exactly so I don't know if you
remember rich but there was um a protest
where um obviously this is horrible
where that guy um drove his car over
some um Muslim people in I think it was
in either in London or in Markham you
know and so they had a protest about
that and the Prime Minister was there
kneeling and crying and whatever though
right you know so but by the same token
Maxim berer had a protest against coid
12 people showed up and he was arrested
and he was like ticketed for violating
coid protocols though right so it's yeah
it depends on what you protest on and
who you are it's not what it's who you
are is is what the issue is yeah they
did the same thing during the whole
George Floyd stuff right it's like you
know you you know you had to get locked
down and take their forc jobs but you
want to burn down a city and flip cars
and loot and Riot and pillage and
plunder that's fine cool no problem yeah
that's uh freedom of freedom of
expression as they would say I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out